attentats qui ont plongé notre pays dans
un immense chagrin
pendant ces épreuves j'ai vu les
français désireux de voir la république
demeurer debout
je les ai vus avec au coeur les valeurs
de la république plus forte que tous les
ferments de divisions d'opposition que
certains s'employait fait renaître dans
notre pays
j'ai vu aussi monsieur le premier
ministre dans l'exercice de ses
responsabilités place beauvau
des policiers les gendarmes les
militaires des responsables et des
agents de la sécurité civile donner le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes s'exposer jusqu'au
sacrifice de leur vie et un carnet
magnifiquement par l'uniforme qu'il
portait la république et l'état de droit
je veux leur dire au moment je quitte
mes fonctions
l'immense gratitude qui est la mienne et
leur dire aussi qu'en raison de ce que
j'ai vu de leur courage
je les emporte avec moi pour toujours
dans mon coeur
enfin monsieur le premier ministre je
vais insister sur le fait que au cours
des cinq dernières années sous
l'autorité du président de la république
de mes prédécesseurs nous avons sur les
questions économiques sur les services
publics sur la politique internationale
pris les décisions qui nous paraissait
juste et bonne pour notre pays et que
les résultats commencent à se faire jour
dont je suis convaincu que l'histoire
reconnaîtra avec le temps qui passe que
ses premiers succès sont imputables à
l'action du président hollande
enfin monsieur le produit je ne veux pas
être trop long c'est à vous qu
appartient maintenant le soin de diriger
notre pays
je veux vous dire devant tous les
personnels de l'hôtel matignon et à
travers eux je m'adresse à tous les
fonctionnaires de la république à ceux
qui m'ont servi dans mes responsabilités
à quel point je suis fier d'eux à quel
point ils sont incarnés magnifiquement
l'esprit de service pub
le sens de la république les valeurs qui
ne devrait jamais cessé de nous unir les
uns aux autres et vous rentrez dans une
maison vous allez exercer la
responsabilité d'un pays où les
fonctionnaires sont valeureux courageux
et engagé
enfin et je terminerai par là je quitte
la responsabilité qui est la mienne
en homme de gauche avec mes convictions
avec les valeurs qui ont été forgés tout
au long d'une éducation et d'une
expérience politique faite de la
fréquentation des cris d'un certain
nombre de grandes consciences de la
gauche pense à léon blum à jean jaurès à
pierre mendès france dans la
fréquentation aussi à la fin de sa vie
de françois mitterrand plus tard de
laurent fabius de françois hollande qui
m'ont souvent montré le chemin et ses
convictions je les emporte avec moi
parce que j'ai la certitude que la
modernisation du pays que j'appelle de
mes voeux comme vous n'est possible que
dès lors qu'il y a dans l'engagement de
chacun qui contribuent à la vie publique
une authenticité un attachement aux
leçons de l'histoire
on ne vient pas de nulle part et si l'on
veut montrer fermement la direction il
faut précisément savoir quels sont ces
héritages dont on est comptable et
auquel on doit se référer toujours si
l'on veut rester fidèle à soi-même et
pour moi je conclurai par là dans ma vie
politique la loyauté la fidélité le
respect de ceux qui on en crée des
courants de pensée dans l'histoire ont
constitué une boussole au même titre que
le sens de l'état
car dans l'exercice des responsabilités
qui auront été les miennes et notamment
dans les épreuves terribles que nous
avons traversé la passion de l'état et
le sens de l'état auront été ma force et
ma seule boussole
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
souhaite
par amitié
par amour de notre pays par amour de la
république le meilleur dans l'exercice
de vos fonctions
[Applaudissements]